hey what's up my name is samuel leeds in
this video i'm going to be answering a
question that comes up all the time
which is about refinancing people say
samuel how do you refinance a house
what's the difference between
refinancing and remortgaging and how
does it work so in this video i'm going
to explain that this is a beginner's
guide and hopefully will give you some
insight and wisdom around these terms
what it means and how you can apply it
to your property investment journey so
before i get started why don't you do me
a massive favor and just hit the like
button that would really help me and it
helps the algorithms so more people can
see the content because i've had this
question so many times
so refinancing first thing i want to say
is this refinancing
and remortgaging are
the same thing so it's just a different
it's just a different expression so let
me explain what a mortgage is first and
i know you probably already know this
but then i'm going to build on it so a
mortgage is a loan right so if you want
to buy a house and let's say the house
is 200 000 pounds
you typically take a mortgage to buy the
house and the mortgage will generally be
if it's if it's a house that you're
buying to rent out that's called a buy
to let house so if the house is a buy to
let house guess what type of mortgage
you're going to get a buy to let
mortgage
and again there's different words for
mortgages a hm home mortgage a
residential mortgage a commercial
mortgage a buy to that mortgage and
someone says oh what does it mean well
all it means is
a mortgage
for appropriate for the property you're
buying so if you're buying a commercial
property then you would need a
commercial mortgage
simple if you're buying a house that
you're going to live in it it's a house
that you're going to live in we call
that a residential home because it's
yours it's residential it's your home if
it's a residential home guess what kind
of mortgage you're gonna get you got it
a residential mortgage so a buy to let
mortgage typically they will lend you 75
percent to buy the house so again if
you're buying a house that's 200 000
pounds and you're buying it for the sole
intent to rent it out as a buy
two let then you're going to get
a 75 bucks mortgage which would be about
150 000 pounds
now here's the interesting part
let's say you buy it let's say you have
a 200 000 pound house
and you've got a mortgage outstanding of
150 000 pounds
you might be thinking oh that's debt pay
it down pay off but i would recommend
not thinking of it like that i would
recommend
leaving the debt
because the rent that you're getting
paid
should assuming that it's a good
property be paying the interest on the
debt and
paying you money which is your passive
income
so the debt's helping you that's what we
call it good debt so why pay off that
debt it's good it's helping you so you
keep the debt
now let's say the property this is where
refinancing comes in let's say the
property goes doubles in value over the
next 10 years let's say you buy it for
200 and then it becomes worth 400 000.
now
that two hundred thousand pounds uplift
the extra profit that you've got in the
house because it's gone up by two
hundred thousand that's your money right
but how do you get it
well you could sell the house
to get the money and then you'd have to
then wait if you sold the house you tell
it for 400 000
you'd get your 50 000 pounds deposit
back plus
bang you get your 200 000 pound uplift
but if you did that though you'd lose
the house
so how can you keep the house
but at the same time get your money
that's when you need to refinance or
remortgage because what you're going to
do the house is worth 200 000 is
refinance means
getting a new mortgage that's what it
means
so if you ever hear someone say oh i'm
refinancing what that means is they're
getting a new mortgage
if your house is worth 400 000
and you refinance it well how much is
the bank gonna lend you well they're
gonna lend you 75 percent
of 400 000 problem what about the
existing mortgage we'll get there so if
the house is now 400 000
and the new lender comes in and goes
well i'll give you 75 of the new value
therefore the new lender is prepared to
give you 300 000 here's what happens the
new lender gives you 300 000 but with
that 300 000 you have to pay the 150 000
so you pay off the old mortgage with the
new mortgage so if they give you a 300
000 mortgage you pay off the 150 000
pounds mortgage and you're left with 150
000 pounds so you got your money from
the refinance but you've still got the
house
your debt on the house has gone up but
so is the value
and now you've pulled the money out by
refinancing now that money how does it
work do they just give it to you does it
just go into your bank do you have to
pay tax on it how does it work yes they
just give it to you they give you that
money
into your bank and you pay zero tax on
that money that is a loan the reason you
pay no tax on the money is because even
though it's technically profit because
your house has gone up in value so
you've gained
and then you've taken the money out
you've taken it out in the form of debt
you've taken it out in the form of a
loan and they the hmrc the government
cannot tax you on debt it's a very
clever way to release money out of a
property without selling the property
because if you sell the property you're
going to pay capital gains tax you're
also going to lose the property now
you've got the money it's tax-free in
your bank you can use that money to buy
more houses and you've still got the
rent coming in so that's why refinancing
is so good now here's some complications
that i need to give you about
refinancing
when you buy a house
you can't refinance it for usually two
to three years and the reason is is
because
let's say you buy a house really cheap
and then you add value and the house
just shoots up in value in the next 12
months you buy it for 100 grand and
after six months it's worth 150. you
can't refinance it because the first
lender
the mortgage company that gave you that
first mortgage will usually tie you into
at least two years of a fixed term
so if after six months you want to get a
new mortgage and pay that old blender
off they'll be like
you've only you've only had the money
six months so you need to pay us
something called early repayment fees
which is usually
a few thousand pounds so if you're
buying a property with the sole purpose
of pushing the value up
and then refinancing it and pulling your
money out you shouldn't buy it with a
mortgage in the first instance you
should buy it with a bridging loan
because a bridging loan is something
that bridges the gap between the
purchase and the refinance i hope this
is making sense when i first learned
this about 14 years ago it blew my mind
i didn't understand it so maybe you have
to watch this video a couple times over
um but if you can get your head around
this it will really help you as a
property investor next next thing maybe
you bought a house and you live in the
house and it's a residential house maybe
you bought the house for 150 grand maybe
it's a flat but it's your home
if your home doubles in value let's say
you bought it for 150 now it's worth 300
can you refinance it and the answer is
yes you can refinance it on a
residential mortgage the only thing to
be mindful of
is that if you're refinancing your home
the new mortgage lender will want to
make sure that you can afford the new
mortgage payments so if you're earning
really low but you've got a house that's
really high in value and you're trying
to get a mortgage on it you might
struggle you might be able to just sell
it and then use the money to reinvest in
property so there's a little bit of a
crash course on refinancing and what it
means i hope you found this video
helpful i'm going to be making more
videos similar to this so hit me with
your questions below and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you